coffee and cats now unless you're
extremely allergic to them
they can be a great summertime pair but
for animal shelters this is known as
kitten season Hearts Alive Village is
open a new cat cafe to get you
caffeinated possibly get you a new pet
Lauren negretti joining us live at
Rainbow and Okie with the story Lauren
good morning surrounded by kitties good
morning surrounded by kitties what a
fantastic morning and place to be here
yes we're at Hearts Alive Village Cat
Cafe okay so to explain more about what
kitten season is I'm joined by Nikki
Martinez director of feline Solutions
good morning good morning that's we're
doing great best title I've ever heard
by the way oh thank you that's a great
job it's a great job and so with that uh
what is kitten season kitten season is
the warm spring and summer months where
kittens are born on the streets so we
are as you can imagine as a rescue
flooded with phone calls of people that
found kittens that need saving or they
want to find a place for them
definitely and so with that too
um some of these cats in here were
rehabilitated Strays as well but what is
a cat cafe how many people how many cats
in here are up for adoption so we have
uh over 40 cats available here at our
Cat Cafe
um someone can pay an entry fee of 15
donation to come and hang out with our
cats pre-packaged snacks and coffee tea
soda water is included in your in your
visit in your entry fee you can hang out
with the cats and get your get your fill
of cats here yeah no I'm having a good
time this is and one of one of the cast
available before adoption right here and
so for more information you go to
heartsalivevillage.org to sign up 15
entry that's actually applied to the
adoption fee of 65 so it goes down 15
bucks if you do plan to adopt but again
book an appointment there is also a buy
one get one for students here so signing
off with a bunch of cats here at the
cats at the cat Village cat excuse me
heart's a live Village uh Cat Cafe Laura
negretti 8 news now back over to you
guys I think you found a friend oh poor
John he's amazing through through
osmosis
my allergies just got activated
subliminally thank you Lauren